alright awesome first a disclaimer this
one is in one-on-one talk so it's
introduction if you're very good in
mathematics or you a statistic in or
something we'll leave now it's just
joking you can stay in the room but
don't expect too much okay before I
start my name is David I work for the
FBI Research Center for information
technology we're a non-profit research
institution located in Casco and we work
on applied informatics and we have a
mission of doing knowledge transfer that
means we try to transfer universitary
research impulses in the industry in the
private sector we have many interesting
applications cybersecurity robotics
assisted living smart mobility systems
autonomous vehicles and last but not
least also the energy sector and I'm
telling you this because well to fulfill
our mission to transfer something we
obviously need some private partners and
we're always looking for companies that
either wish to just get in or start a
project with us or that want to be
participate in some publicly funded
research project so if you're interested
in this oh and the end this particular
thing well don't hesitate to approach me
or go on our website there's a lot of
nice people on there which all work
there which can answer you every
question you probably might have around
this all right let's go on what our
particular doing and I was very pleased
about the talk before because it just
introduces or motivates what I'm
actually trying to do is well we have an
energy transition to to face that means
we will have high share of renewable
energy energy generation in the future
energy sector and that also means that
we cannot go any further with just you
switch on anything as the moment you
like but because because we will have
energy or electricity available once
they wind is blowing or Sun shines and
that means we can either was really put
a lot of money into storage technology
or we try to flexible eyes our demand
and that's what we're trying to do we
try to develop
algorithms actually make demand more
flexible and my particular case it's
about building so try to optimize energy
consumption behavior of buildings to
make it more efficient but also to to
make it such that it stabilized the
energy grid and as I'm not trying to do
it with one building because one
building won't stabilize the grid
obviously I try to do to develop
approaches that actually work on a large
number of buildings and that motivates
for me using machine learning or
particular reinforcement learning
actually but I'm facing the same issues
yet you taught before some all about
tackling the sample efficiency issue
okay so what we're starting with machine
learning a few years ago I just hooked
up some some tutorial books and I've
read like okay you have a regression
task go for mean squared error or you
have a classification task then go for
cross entropy and anyway if you once you
apply your your your loss functions you
need to optimize to get a good results
and you should apply still has the
gradient descent our little disclaimer
you can apply usual gradient descent
without the stochastic part two but I
will use it soon anomalously here in the
stalk because it doesn't really matter
to my point of view but the question I
ask myself is why so I really try to
understand what's happening if I apply
such a system because of it if I don't
if I just feel like the guy in the comic
who just has a huge pile of machine
learning something and poking it all the
time then this might sometimes work and
I might find a an algorithm that
actually solves chess or something by a
chance but I don't really understand how
it worked anyway and that's what really
bothered me so what I'm trying to do is
actually I really try to get into the
theory and understand why do we use
those loss functions why are they
recommended approach and why do we why
does it work at all and I tried at least
a bit of sharing that with you so you
might hopefully have an intuition
afterwards not all the mass I will show
you a lot of math by the way that's not
too important but hopefully an intuition
what actually happens behind the scenes
so let's get going first thing we're
going to do is mean squared error and in
the beginning of any data science
project you probably have some data okay
so this is our sample data set for the
moment we have n vectors of input
features and we have n corresponding
vectors of targets so we denoted the the
input data features as a capital X and
you're the one that's capital y and you
might for a simple example just that one
you see up off there so it's just the x
axis is our features the y axis are our
targets and what you see is just some
samples we observed and either every
point every Green Point is one
particular example we observed so what
we're not going to do is or what
supervised learning is all about this to
my opinion is finding a function that
generalizes those observed data so what
you see in the plot is actually a blue
line that is the true data generating
function which we do not know and in
reality but we try to fit a function
that actually comes close to our unknown
function or at least to do at least come
close to that I think to what we think
later will be the true denature data
generating function the nice thing is if
you perceive supervised learning as this
is you don't have an artificial
intelligence problem which seems like oh
[ __ ] how should I solve for that
how should I solve artificial
intelligence but all you need to do is
curve fitting and curve fitting looks
much more nice from a mathematical point
of view I think one thing we can observe
in here is that we that our points that
we observe are not from our two data
generating function but we have some
noise on top and that noise is usually
like any real process will have some
noise in there too the question is just
how large it is and the noise adds a
stochastic element into a problem so
what it means for us is we cannot just
fit the points directly we need some
statistical tools to do so and the tools
that were usually applying a called
maximum likelihood estimation maximum
likelihood estimation is for now just a
very simple concept it says that we
should use those parameters for the best
parameters that we can find for a
function approximator are those that
Maxim
the likelihood of observing our targets
if we give in our features into the
system and adjust at the parameters okay
that sounds a bit abstract probably and
it doesn't really give us a way to
compute stuff so if we assume iid data
which is common assumption especially in
machine learning then we can compute us
as just the product of all the
probabilities for every single example
that we've observed okay so every point
in our chart it's just we've got to
compute one probability for it and then
we're just gonna make a huge product out
of it
that's correct from a mathematical point
of view the point is is not very nice to
compute because you're gonna multiply a
lot of zeros and that's gonna be in the
end it's just zero or close to zero the
point is what you usually people doing
is they will make a logarithm around of
it like put a introduce a logarithm here
that doesn't change the position of our
best parameters we find but it just
changes the value of the probability
function and so it's okay from a
mathematical point of view and what
people also do is I don't know you know
machine learning people they don't like
maximizing stuff they like to minimize
error so they put a minus on top of it
and then they're gonna call this
negative log likelihood and the point is
why I'm telling you this is that this
term is quite common in machine learning
literature you will find on all over the
way as soon as someone is bit more fancy
then we'll talk about negative log
likelihood so you have an idea hopefully
now where this term is coming from okay
so this was a bit mathematic obviously I
try to give you an example how this
works
okay so we're gonna make I think the
fundamental and most easiest example I I
consider it is fitting a Gaussian
distribution through some observed data
points we have a probability density
function of a Gaussian and please note
now that for those who are strong
mathematics they know that this is wrong
would have denoted like didn't a the
notation is wrong this is I for a
discrete probability distribution please
ignore it it yields the same results it
I don't want to explain
all the differences between continuous
and discrete cases here - because it
doesn't fit into 30 minutes but apart
from that the general intuition remains
the same what you see here is the
probability density function of a
Gaussian that means does the blue curve
you see here and the blue curve is just
giving us an intuition about in a area
under that curve how likely are we to
observe data here so speaking of that we
have very likely to observe data here
and not very likely to observe data here
and what you see also here is some green
points it should be 10 of them actually
that our samples derived from this
distribution so our problem that we're
now trying to solve is is how can we
reconstruct that blue curve that we
don't know and what we're going to use
is we're going to apply maximum
likelihood estimation that means we're
gonna in that cars minimize the
probability or a logarithmic the
probability of observing data points
from a Gaussian distribution while we
optimize our mean and standard deviation
as parameters and if we're going to do
that you get this result the nice thing
about gaussians is that gaussians are
actually very simple as we heard and
talked yesterday - if you got into that
gaussian progress talk go scenes are
very simple and that means if you have a
Gaussian distribution you can actually
solve this equation with conventional
classical extreme value analysis like
you did in 12 grade I think okay and if
you do so also for that weight if you do
so if you apply what we've just learned
before maximizing probability you will
receive just a an estimator the maximum
likelihood estimator for a Gaussian
distribution is actually just the
arithmetic mean so it's not very
surprising at all okay same for standard
deviation you just do differentiation
set to zero solve for standard deviation
and the maximum likelihood estimator is
well what you usually or at least nearly
compute a standard deviation apart from
some minor minus one that's usually
added here okay and if you do that
actually and you reconstruct the
Gaussian distribution you see that from
our ten points we can't reconstruct it
all
Gaussian the original one was at with a
mean at ten and a standard deviation of
one and the reconstructed one has been
nine point nine five and standard
deviation of one point zero five so it's
quite fairly okay but that not so much
data we perceived so yeah you're trying
to apply machine learning don't you I do
what may tales tell me well David I
don't want to fit gaussians I don't care
I want to have a fancy neural network so
how does it relate well let's try to
generalize that so what we all we do is
to generalize this to general machine
learning and unsupervised learning in
particular is all we can assume is that
we have a function now that generates a
mean and that function might be our
neural network or linear regression well
whatever doesn't really matter so far
and then we are going to assume that our
points have been sampled from this
function but with some standard
deviation around it with some Gaussian
noise and we're gonna apply our function
here a function approximator with our
parameters and the features as main and
gonna put all true observed values here
and what we're gonna have is now the
probability of observing data at any
point on our function approximator and
to give you a more of intuition how this
look like how this might look like is
have a look here this one and this plot
the the right curve is actually the the
mean of the function approximator the
green dots are samples and the contour
plot in the back is the probability of
observing data okay and what you see
here is that your probability of
observing data in that particular case
is just like a tube around our mean so
that's at least something okay
this is the hopefully a last slide with
a really lot of math on it maybe maybe
not what we now do if we're gonna apply
this okay this general framework is we
just gonna try four parameters max make
a maximum likelihood estimation again
plug in our function and
and we receive some function which I
which I do not expect you to read too
much at the point is we can simplify it
a bit we can reinsert our an estimator
for a standard deviation that we
computed before for Gaussian and what we
will receive in the end is this one here
and I think that one looks quite
familiar to most of you because that one
is just ordinary mean squared error so
the very point of this slide is actually
this one that minimizing mean squared
error is equivalent to applying maximum
likelihood estimation that we under the
assumption of Gaussian noise okay
so that's why mean square error actually
works so the one one last thing we have
to solve now is we have to solve the
differentiation problem and what we're
going to do there is we're gonna apply
stochastic gradient descent and the
reason for that is actually that if we
or if we would try to apply analytic
extreme value analysis that means that
we have to for every function
approximated every time you change
something in your neural network you
have to make a recomputation of your
analytic approach to find maximum values
okay and then I think of my most complex
function approximation see probably
won't find no analytic solution at all
so what people do in that and indeed to
circumvent this is they make stochastic
gradient descent and that just means we
have we compute our loss on that case
the main square error at a particular
starting point we're going to follow
that gradient gonna compute the gradient
that is just the differentiation at that
point regarding to the loss function the
parameters follow the gradient some
distance and then we do the
recomputation again until we met some
stopping criterion and hopefully at
least somewhere got close to some
minimum of the Ovilus function okay so
what does it imply well the the point is
that we if we comply main square error
and still has the gradient descent what
it yields us is a universal tool for
fitting any differential function to
data assuming Gaussian noise and utilize
the maximum likelihood estimation under
the hood the point about Gaussian noise
it's a reasonable default choice for
real distortions much of measurement
error is actually or often assumed
closed to be Gaussian noise but you
should be aware that there are actually
problems exist about this is not the
case okay one particular example is mean
time to failure of machines which is
awfully assumed to be viable
distribution and if you try to predict
one of those systems where you have a
very strong assumption that your error
is not Gaussian distributed that this
might not work or might at least not
give you good results then there's
maximum likelihood estimation if you
apply classical maximum likelihood
estimation you have to guarantees that
are very very nice well the first one is
that maximum likelihood estimation is
actually asymptotically the best
estimator in terms of convergence if you
have if your number of examples reaches
infinity so that's good because it tells
us okay this is the best estimator you
can get and in the other hand it also
tells there's a guarantee that we can
find a true generating data generating
function if our approximator can
resemble it and if we have infinite
today infinite infinity data infinite
data okay don't worry the problem with
that is that relies on the assumption
that you are actually found the extreme
value and if you are not able to do so
which is the case for stochastic
gradient descent then this might not be
guaranteed anymore you might still find
or you can hope for that it still
somehow applies but you don't have any
guarantee for it and that's actually the
catch if you applies to has the gradient
descent that you should be aware of okay
so an indifference to other optimization
methods where for example in convex
problem and you can have big guaranteed
to find the extreme value one last thing
about how how does it work well I wanted
hope or now sorry I told you in the
beginning that our trying to give you an
intuition what actually happens and I
try to do is with this slide what you
see here is a training process
for example we seen before and this one
here is just the initial values so the
initial values as I defined them this is
the logistic function we're trying to
fit your data the green points here are
actually our observed data again and you
see here that our fitted function is
very far away from this one here the
contour plot is the computer standard
deviation and what now happens while we
train is actually that the mean of the
function approximator gets closer and
closer to a real data and as it does
this it can actually reduce the standard
deviation and that means that the points
that are actually close to the mean have
a higher probability value and that's
what's really happening under the hood
if you apply main squared error okay so
once we hopefully got a little further
here next one is cross-entropy
well cross-entropy is usually used to
classify images or as a classification
loss function and say you have those
images of cute animals I'm not sure if I
have ever seen a cute fish but it could
be close to that and what you not try to
do is solve all your data would look
like this you have like your features
are actually your images and your
targets are just a one hot encoded label
which tells you what is it so this has a
hundred percent probability of being a
dog and this has a 100 percent
probability of being a cat and so on so
forth what we're now trying to do is are
now sorry one thing I should tell you
about this is that we can assume this as
a probability distribution to so similar
to our Gaussian we have seen before we
can also assume that this is a multi
Noli distribution and that multi no
distribution describes as the
probability of observing that particular
category and it has nearly no
constraints apart from that every
probability must be equal to zero or
larger or and that all the sum of all
probabilities must be equal to one
what we're actually done trying to do is
this we have our target data and we have
a model or predictive distribution and
we try to make them equal and at the
moment you see there that this doesn't
match their good so what we actually
need to do is we need to compare
probability distributions and the thing
which is usually well or often apply to
compare probability distribution is
called Coburg light metal virgins and
it's a bit okay and this one's really
the last month light I promise it falls
a bit from the sky now and but the point
about Coburg Ladner divergence is that
this here
this particular term here can be
interpreted as also a maximum likelihood
estimator but it's it's the maximum
likelihood estimator that those
distributions actually identical or
yields identical samples not going too
much into detail here the point about
the Coburg lab that divergence what
sorry is that it actually that you can
transform it and you can make two parts
of that one is called channel entropy
it's relevant for information theory but
it's not dependent on our system so we
can just drop it out for our
optimization problem and the second one
is called cross entropy and the point I
was trying to make with the slide is
that given the assumption of Cobre light
Coburg light no divergence you can
actually will find a reason why you can
why you should use cross entropy because
minimizing the cross entropy term here
is equivalent to minimizing Coburg
Ladner divergence which makes the
distributions as equal as possible okay
practical example computing cross
entropy is actually very easy all you do
is you make you take the the PC value
here for every category first example as
1.0 times the logarithm of the
probability of observing it from your
predicted distribution that 0.3 that's
this term here and then we're gonna make
the same one for the second category and
for the third one and so on and so forth
that's all it does and what does it tell
us well you could say that cross-entropy
is a combination in combination with
multinomial distributions the 7a used
for loss function as a loss function for
classification
however cross-entropy is actually not
limited to this ok so you can the point
is about that cross-entropy can be used
to fit arbitrary probability
distributions also not limited to
discrete distributions as multi Noli but
you can also use it for continuous cases
and also interesting is that if you
apply a Gaussian distribution to your
cross entropy what you will receive in
the end is actually called as just
maximum likelihood now sorry main
squared error so that's a bit of a point
so actually cross entropy is actually
Demeter loss function and you can kind
of use it if you have for example other
loss function or other noises then you
could use this as a starting point to
generate your own loss functions would
which would probably find better results
we'll hopefully at least ok
so that leaves me with a summary so what
why do we use main squared error
well because minimizing MSE is
equivalent to maximizing the likelihood
of observing our data from our function
approximator while we adjust our
parameters and assume Gaussian noise and
Gaussian noise is usually a reasonable
default choice also why do we apply
stochastic gradient descent because
applying stochastic gradient descent
removes the requirement for symbolic
differentiation and this allows us a
relatively free choice of a function
approximator why do we use cross entropy
well because minimizing cross entropy is
equivalent to maximizing your likelihood
the two probability distributions are
identical and what else should you know
well you should know that some
applications may benefit from assuming
alternative error distributions and you
could use cross entropy as a starting
point there and you should also know
that some functions may allow more
robust methods then stochastic gradient
descent to minimize the loss especially
if you can
Jim convex behavior that's all for me
thanks very much
one last thing before we go to the
slides if you ever wonder well there's
so much information on there where the
source from this talk is actually
inspired by by me reading this book by
young good fellow where all main
findings are based on this publication
except especially from these sections
pointed out here and also use some
medium article towards data science calm
which inspired the Gaussian example and
now I'm happy for remarks and questions
so go ahead thank you very much
I can really recommend that book as well
can you take us through the intuition of
the two terms of the kullback-leibler of
the the Shannon and cross-entropy like
how those line up and also how would you
would you use the cross entropy if we
were to say to use a gal a Weibull
distribution of noise on the example you
had before how would we go about that
with the cross entropy yeah well common
intuition about and like Shannon entropy
is often called in information theory as
the maximum maximum amount of
information or bits you use to to
compress that information so if
something is very probable has some
discrete probabilities of happening say
an event yeah say you roll a dice and
you want to know what is the most
effective way of compressing this
information in a bit way or any other
computational method then this gives you
an lower bound for it and actually cross
entropy is related to the usual Shannon
entropy by telling you how what is the
lower bound if you try to compress this
information but with a wrong assumption
of the distribution so how much
information will get that there's a very
clear for you know
say that one more time so this one here
is lower bound for the optimal
compression rate so if you have
probabilities and the observed events
and you try to find the minimum
compressed version of how you can encode
this and bits and bytes for example then
give this gives you a lower bound here
and this one here but it assumes a
certain probability so it will make a
higher or larger a bit sequence for
events that occur less often so that's
why it in the end will be a highly
compressed and this one here is
basically the same apart from that that
it gives gives you the the information
about how much how is the lower bound if
you assume a wrong probability
distribution so that's pretty well at
least one interpretation place hi thanks
for the hoe and so as you said using a
custom loss function makes sense if your
noise is not cost and distributed so how
do you know in practice that your noise
is not Gaussian distributed so it seems
like first you have to fit the model and
then in order to quantify the noise and
how our deviates from the novel so air
from the from the model so would you say
just use assume a Gaussian noise and
then look at the noise and then look at
the distribution of the noise well that
could probably work I think it's
actually a thing of the my knowledge I
think that probably did the best
starting point if you have some
theoretic knowledge about what's
happening under the hood then you this
model EF if you model a physical process
for example you might know this or
another example could be you know that
you have a sensor but there's a sense of
software and it just cuts away unlogical
values so you know okay you don't have a
clear Gaussian anymore because it's
shifted a bit and you try to find
another distribution which fits it
better I wanted to ask you about cross
entropy how would it work to fit the
model if the targets are not one hot
encoded like classes one zero zero
but for example the dog can be 0.8 and
at point one and fish also point one
like this one yeah but not clearly one
zero zero but you know it's the same
concept so if you have like here a zero
point eight and zero zero point one and
zero point one here then you would just
have here at zero point eight and here
at zero point one and here is zero point
one and in fact that's what people
actually do it because if you compute
this function here and you have a
softmax function in before you as your
output function or in your network then
you will have an infinite you have to
have an infinite input to receive a one
so actually there's some some approach
but what people try to arbitrarily
reduce those those values here in order
to prevent exploring exploding ways but
it still works nevertheless so even even
though if you're not very sure about
this and you can also use a sample where
you're not sure about how does if that's
really a dog if you say it could be a
dog but it could be a cat and you could
also assign 50/50 probability and that
they and you still use the sample okay
please do that yes so yeah time is up
let's thank David again and if you have
more questions just come over here